i don't know what's going to happen now
this is one now now put your hands back
a little bit
we talked about the guys that might be
dangerous this is one of those guys
okay is this a caracal it looks like a
length of that leash yeah i'll grab it
now
if he jumps off make sure he doesn't
strangle himself obviously oh okay
you've thought this through nicely yeah
i'm gonna give you a short leash and
then tell it to jump yeah uh so big
doesn't seem to press like you would no
obviously it looks a lot like a lynx hi
buddy
yeah boy now that's for those big toughs
on their ears but this is a southern
african animal okay he's now going this
way you can let him jump down
okay all right make sure he doesn't hurt
himself coming out
what's the danger here what would be
these guys
these guys are excellent
what you want to pay attention to
obviously is that all of his body
postures tell me he's totally
comfortable with you
but even at this age at one year old you
know he does have teeth he does have
claws
cody
there's lots of space on the couch no no
this kitty made it quite clear
beautiful beautiful animal these guys my
favorite thing about these guys is that
they can actually catch birds out of the
air so if a bird wants to fly over its
head oh it can leap in the air and keep
in the air and catch it
bring a bird yeah
good joy oh now he's changing his mind
about who
it is and no
you guys have the same hair color wow
beautiful beautiful animal and uh we
should probably move on
am i in danger right now uh well it's
not looking like it's coming after you
anyway let me grab them from you oh good
what's that oh my god
yeah we probably want to get him away
before the next guy comes yeah you don't
want to these animals should not mate
so what do i grab this guy
i'm like hi buddy goodness okay
good boy all right what what's what's
this all about what's this
monitor lizard you want to hold this guy
as well uh you tell me do
i do i want to hold this guy this guy
definitely is
dangerous he's got big teeth and they
have a really bad bite this tail would
whip you
but you can see he's pretty calm pretty
relaxed check him out like that you want
to hold him
so what you want to do stand up
you put this hand like that okay and i'm
going to grab them
oh god this now you put your hand
underneath his chest like i got like
other hand for his tail okay so you can
see those claws
this hand let me go let me get this hand
okay i'm watching can you have this hand
[Applause]
he's trying to hold on
[Applause]
now they all know the conan that we know
[Music]
gonna say it's shockingly lifelike
okay this guy actually climbs trees so
what he's doing is holding on he knows
how to climb trees so he uses his tails
he'll sharp claws yeah hold on to you
yeah he's totally comfortable going into
my ribs
uh this isn't what is this
okay because when you i was so scared in
the front part i wasn't listening to a
word you said
sometimes is the petting a good idea or
is that yeah he's fine with it you can
see
he's totally relaxed he's got a good
grip of you you know
he's fine he likes that kind of stuff
now these guys i mean he's only five
feet he can be about seven
feet they can catch basically anything
that's smaller than them right pretty
good predators
all right well this is an incredible
segment oh yeah
i'm trying to try that i don't know how
we're gonna get this off because
i'm pretty sure that's it for the rest
yeah it's hanging onto everything for
dear life what's that
we have one more i didn't know if we had
time for one more oh really okay i don't
know how we topped the old
penis gag clearly my
this this thing better be good
whatever's coming
bring it out oh you're gonna come take
this away from me
let me grab that guy okay here we go all
right there we go and that's my heart
okay if you're having on your life okay
good
and then